you know I I guess people are liking my
advice you know I'm just out here given
relationship advice you know take it or
leave it you know what I mean so my
pregnant wife of 10 years is cheating on
me so this is a story from Reddit that I
was sent and asked to respond to so my
pregnant wife of 10 years is cheating on
me
wow
about six weeks ago we found out my wife
is pregnant about six hours ago I found
out she was cheating on me I wish I
could make this up and I swear it feels
like a bad dream I'm so shocked and
upset I've been with my wife for 10
years this year I thought our
relationship is great and I've never
felt more comfortable or happy we are
both 28. I'm gonna make this incredibly
long story short she has been cheating
with me for the last month and a half
with her ex apparently they talked on
Facebook when she reached out to him to
tell him happy birthday she instigated
by doing this I'm assuming they slept
together three times and hung out six
she was going to TJ Maxx sending me
pictures of baby clothes but also
hanging out with him this woman is my
world I did everything for her I was so
excited for this baby what we were
trying she swears it's mine and there's
no way it's his she but she lied saying
they only slept together once he told me
three times when she finally admitted it
she said she told them she loved him but
didn't mean it my thing is how would she
love him after only a month they dated
like 13 years ago it's just hard for me
to believe and I'm questioning If the
child is even mine it's literally the
worst day of my life guys I'm terrified
my anxiety is awful I feel so sick she's
texting me saying she wants to work it
out but she's so shady apparently she
turned off Life 360 and her mom noticed
something was up it didn't tell me come
to find out she told her mom she saw saw
him but they were talking and nothing
more I have Life 360 on my phone because
my brother sister and wife wanted to be
in the loop with where I was which is
fine but I don't use it to track them
and never have I trusted her 100 it
doesn't feel real I'm hoping this is a
bad Nightmare and I have anxiety and
it's freaking me out so bad I can't
believe she did this to me we have a
home together all of our finances are
together this is the life I wanted and
now I don't know how to move on I'm so
betrayed she was the sweetest woman I've
ever met and I'm in shock and I don't
know how to feel
so this is actually a really common
Story one of the most common ways that
women cheat one is with men at work but
two is with ex-boyfriends and guys this
is why body count is so important
because women
for whatever reason we cannot go down
we we can't our our Natures once we hit
a certain lifestyle we can't go down you
know it's the same thing with men
unfortunately you know if we get a guy
that makes us feel a certain way
even even if it's not logical because a
lot of times guys will be like okay you
left me for a drug dealer you left me
for a criminal well the Criminal made us
you know feel a certain way we don't we
don't operate on logic we operate on our
feelings so the problem is
um a lot of women well
have an ex-boyfriend that they liked
better and if they get the chance
they'll go back and they'll cheat
unfortunately so and the other thing is
um just a red flag that I notice in
relationships women that wait a long
time to have kids after they get married
I just don't see them as that into the
guy because I mean think about it guys
guys women
want kids so bad with the top 10 20 of
dudes that they will literally
tell men that they're not on birth
control they'll steal condoms they'll do
all of this so I'm like if you've been
with a chick for 10 years
and she hasn't even tried you know I
mean I'm not saying she should but my
point is in my experience typically when
women want when a woman wants a kid with
a guy like it's immediate like if he's
that guy to her that's just my
experience
um
the other thing that I noticed is this
woman is my world so what does that tell
us when guys say that a woman is their
world
it's messing up the natural order of
things because he put her above himself
and women we hate it when you make us
the center of your world it is repulsive
to us we hate it
um another thing I I another thing I
noticed is I trusted her a hundred
percent
we're women you know what I mean it's
like and I don't say this I don't say
this to like to not I don't say this to
on women but guys we have a nature
and women are just a bit more especially
socially manipulative there are good
women that aren't going to use that part
of themselves but we have an inherent
nature and and that's the point so you
know guys let me know what you think in
the comments maybe I'm crazy uh my
advice to Reddit guy
Leave Her She's Gotta Go
um I know I know she's
you love her and all that stuff but okay
one kid look at even if the kid is yours
and I know I know you're like Pearl you
say keep the families together
this is too much this is I I don't think
there's any coming back from this so I
think if he stays with her it's just
gonna be a lifetime of misery
sometimes there's double standards but
let me know what you guys think in the
comments guys like the video on your way
out
um subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time